des collèges moins énergivores le
département investi plus de 550 millions
d'euros pour reconstruire améliorer les
performances des bâtiments ou menées des
travaux d'entretien dans les
établissements et pour faire face aux
changements climatiques la collectivité
végétalisée réaménage les cours de
récréation 3 opérations ont déjà été
réalisées durant l'été et l'année
prochaine onze nouveaux collèges seront
concernés donc à la fois on travaille le
la végétalisation l'impermédiation des
sols
du mobilier des endroits dans lequel
il y a des endroits calmes des endroits
de jeu pour que les peaux soient des
pauses ou vraiment les collégiens
passent d'un bon moment dans un
environnement pas trop chaud le
département veut également des repas
plus locaux pour ces jeunes l'objectif
est d'atteindre une part de 26% de
produits yvelinois dans l'assiette des
collégiens d'ici à la fin de l'année sur
la politique éducative les Yvelines vont
poursuivre le déploiement d'ISI ce
cartable numérique composé d'une
tablette avec clavier d'applications
après 21 établissements les élèves de 6e
et 4e et enseignant de 37 collèges vont
être équipés cette année c'est un vrai
plus ça permet vraiment de réduire la
fracture numérique vous savez que on
s'est rendu compte pendant le covid
qu'il y avait quand même beaucoup de
collégiens qui n'avaient pas accès à un
ordinateur ou un écran autre qu'un
smartphone et donc ça c'est vraiment
extrêmement important au delà des usages
pédagogiques qu'on peut avoir une
tablette c'est aussi de faire de la
vraie solidarité et ça c'est aussi l'ADN
du département parmi les autres
nouveautés le département intensifie la
présence des chargés de prévention dans
les collèges 38 établissements dans les
Yvelines ont aujourd'hui le leur ils
peuvent intervenir auprès des jeunes
notamment sur la question du harcèlement
scolaire et à l'approche des JO de Paris
2024 les sports olympiques seront à
l'honneur au travers d'ateliers
d'événements qui se dérouleront tout au
long de l'année